Hello everybody *waves*
My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to reading your comments
MAMA MIA
UH HERE I GO AGAIN
AHHH WHAT *explosion*
Hey Mark I know how to make holy water
1. put water in a pot
2. turn on the stove
3. burn the HELL out of it
*Thinks* Could that work?
*scream* THIS DIDN'T GO AS PLANNED
BWAHH how tall are you for real
you're probably 27 I am sssssixteen years younger than you
and I'm 5'2" if you're shorter I'm gonna die laughing
What have you got against people that are short?
Why are you laughing at people that are short?
What does it matter?
You're 16 years younger than me
that means you're...
Eleven! You're eleven
and that's *stutters* you're *stutters more* that's that's NOT THAT TALL
So as far as you're concerned
I'm...FFF.... two - I'm one foot one
That's how tall I am
You take a ruler, a foot-long ruler
add an inch, get a baker's dozen of inches,
and that's me, okay? That's me, alright?
MARK, THE SQUIRRELS NEED THEIR KING
THEY ARE CALLING FOR YOU MARK
GO TO THEM!!!
I gotta tell them to stfu
I'm trying to read some comments here, shut up!!
DANCE LIKE A BANANA
Hey Markyballz
Tell us another embarrassing story. The last one was greeaaat
oh uh I'm glad you get so much joy outta my embarrassment
well I got one for you
Uhhh, back in high school I had a lot of acne
and by that I mean I had a LOT of acne
uh, *insecure chuckle* so much acne that my dad
thought it would be a good idea to enroll me
to enroll me in a MEDICAL STUDY for an experimental
Treatment for acne
and and....and this may not seem embarrassing to you
but at the time I was EXTREEEEMELY self conscious about it
so when you're in a MEDICAL study
you're gonna have a whole bunch of doctors poking at your face
and this is me this is..this is like PUBESCENT Markiplier here
I'm like 15 or something
and I'm sitting in a chair, and there's AAAAALLLL these nurses
and doctors, various people poking at my face
they drew with a sharpie straight down my nose
and straight across my face
to segment my face into four separate
posi *giggle* muh like four separate segments
so that they could have one a control segment
and then three different experimental treatments
that they had me place for like THREE WEEKS
and it was great on the ssss on the ones that worked
but then I just had like this big patch of acne on the untreated segment
so they were like "OH YEAH! Oh this isn't just you NATURALLY getting better
oh this is our treatment! Well GOOD LUCK  here's 50 bucks FUCK OFF now
*chuckle* have fun with your quarter acne face"
and I had to live with that for a while but THAT was...that was...that was fun
MARK SAY MY NAME!!!!!!!!!!!!
I'm from Australia and I'm currently in bed with
a concussion and super bored with a soon-to-be scar
on my forehead so PLEASE...my name
is pronounced so differently over in America
LOVE hearing different accents
Love you and your videos xoxoo ;D
JO...GEORGIA  LOU
JORG GEEORJIA LAOWWW
Guiorgia Loowa
GUI GOR GI LOOwa
GAR GI LOU
GOR GI LA OOOOO, Gambi  Loowa Gary goo
KANGAROO!!!! You're from Australia KANGAROOOOOOOO!!!!!!!
I GOT IT!!! Did I get it? *I have no clue Markimoo the Kangaroo*
MARK OH MY GAGAGAAAA
YOURORORORORORAAAAAAAAAAAAA
I don't even know how
to answer this one-oh my god
My cat wants me DEAD!
YOUR CAT IS PLOTTING YOUR DEMISE!!!
Finish it first!
WITH A DECISIVE STRIKE!!!
or...I don't know
maybe you need to talk out your personal problems?
OR KILL IT
FOOK me and SOOK me
I don't think I want to do either of those things Seth
Are you a member of the butter gluttons?
Am I cool yet? *no*
I feel pretty cool
"Mark can you summon Satan live in one of your videos???"
I ALREADY DID IT!!!
HUWATCH  POOOOOOORN
OH YEAH
OH THAT'S THE GOOD STUFF
OH LOOK AT THAT
Hey Mark! you should come to Alaska
you got a lot of fans up here that would love to see you!
I would love to go to Alaska. I-I would love just to see the
landscape and the wilderness out there
because one of the things that I've
learned to appreciate a lot is....America's
national park system and we have an
astonishing National Park System there's
nothing like it in the rest of the world
uh just in the sheer magnitude of it
and I'm not even just talking about one park
we have like hundreds hundreds and
hundreds of national preserves and parks
an-and Alaska is this one huge wild untamed
wilderness I mean obviously it's super
cold up there but you know not always
and I would love to go and see it and I
want to see all of the all the national
parks that the US has and then go
internationally and see all of the
wonders of the world I want to be well
traveled some day because Amy and I just
went out to Joshua Tree which is another
park and it's this beautiful, beautiful land, mountains
and rocks and these weird trees they
call Joshua trees that apparently flower
once every 10 years. It's just there's so
much to see out there and I want to
experience it all so hopefully I get an excuse to someday.
Hey Mark how old were you when you had your first kiss? *ooh*
I can't remember if I talked about this before,
but my first kiss was interesting
because it was at a.... it was at like sophomore year
homecoming in my high school and it was
with a girl who I had not gone there
with who had come with a friend of mine
I was there alone I was there just you
know going stag you know totally by
choice you know I didn't want to go with a date or anything
but then when I got there I met up with my, uh, buddy Garrett
who was there with his date...uh...and then
later on in the night, one thing led to another....
and then I ended up making out with his date I do I do not
encourage that behavior it was dumb
uh she said they came there as friends
Oh man that was, that was not- oh my god just one
of those memories, you know that feeling that you get
what do you think back in something bad that you did
And you're like, "Ah, shit, why did you do that???"
stupid high school days- I'm 27 now what the fuck do I care?
AH IT'S DEVASTATING MY BRAIN!!!! OH MY MEMORIES!! OH THE HORROR!!!
Garrett and I are fine...maybe..I haven't talked to him in yeeears!!
Do you like to crash onto folding tables? It is funny.
not anymore! Foldy's all long dead and gone. *thunder*
These action lessons are paying off!
Mark please crash on the table
I can't! He's DEAD! DON'T YOU KNOW THAT LEIGH HOULE?!?! *Whispers* he's dead. *more thunder*
BEHBEBEBEBEBE
Ok fuck. ;D
"Hey Mark just like you have done with
YouTube I'm also starting my journey
with photography how did ya keep
yourself motivated?" Well to be perfectly
honest, like, motivation is fleeting.
Motivation is a temporary state of being
it's some people like some people get
confused by they think like to carry you to your goals you're going to be
motivated the entire way-no you're not.
You're going to hit periods where things
slow down and they just turn into a slog
and it's just it's it's like it really
does become a chore no matter how much
you love something if you do it all the
time you will get tired of it
but what the real struggle is is finding it again.
You have to dig deep and always be
looking back on what makes what you do
so special to you what makes it so
important remember why in the beginning
why you wanted to pursue it
and that's why I'm bringing back reading
your comments and I know it's been over
a year since the last one but I'm
bringing it back just because I
remembered why I did in the first
place because it was another avenue to
interact with you guys and it was
another way to get feedback from you
guys and also another way for me to
express myself and in in the creation of
videos or in the creation of photography
like you you have to always always find
new and old ways to keep yourself
motivated and never lose sight of the
original vision that you have. Even if
the goal has changed the original reason
why is usually always the same unless
you need to find a new reason why but
it's a challenge it's a struggle but you can do it!
Mark, if you don't do a flip you'll have bad luck.
OH GAAAAAWD!!!!!
Naaaaaailed it?
Chica: Boooo you suck!
Show us your scars please.
*shrugs* All right
I have a standing desk now I gotta get I'm naa I'm 1'1"
Very short there's my belly. *wolf whistle*
there's my belly button here's my second
belly button from that scar here's this
scar, that was a straight incision
down here, that's not just sweet abs
that's a nice scar. Make sense? Cool beans!
okay here's another one there's
another one there's another one oh boy
Ok. did you all enjoy my tum-tum?
I know I did. You're brave, Mark. You had the
courage to play That Dragon Cancer for
us regardless of what you've been
through. I know personally I couldn't do
that because I have too much anxiety and
stress levels. It is you know I-I don't
want to say I'm the bravest person in
the world for playing that game but that
game was it was pretty heavy for me. Uh, but
the one thing that I think is important
to know about me is that I don't look
back at the time...of-I don't look back at me
losing my dad as the great tragedy of my life
I wish it were any other way like of
course I do, I would love to have my dad
around today but I...I take that loss and
I, once again, I used it to keep pushing me
forward. You know, I-I use it as
motivation to imagine what would make my dad proud.
because I-I-I remember the lessons that my
dad taught me my whole life and I
remember that he was a good dad and he
was probably the best dad I could ever hope for
and he was just always such a good
person, and so I use that to try to
emulate who he was and carry on that
spirit, because I am my father's son
and just because cancer took him away
doesn't mean that he's gone from my life
and that's always important
MARK DON'T READ THIS!!!!!
OH GOOOOOD!!!!!!
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
SO that is all the time I got for
reading your comments today, thank you
everybody so much for watching. I know it
has been over a year since the last
episode and I honestly didn't even know
if I was going to bring the series back
but just this past weekend I took a long
break and I was watching old videos and
I was listening to the old, like, music
that I had stored up and I was-I was
just remembering all these cool moments
of the past and and I was remembering
also like I can just keep making them
like it doesn't have to be in the past I
can always make them, so I was reading
through the last video I did which was
the marching band one and I just I loved
every moment of it
I loved the silliness of it I loved the
the fun of it the seriousness of the
emotions of it. It gives me a reason to talk
to you guys and it gives me a reason to
see everything that you make, and that's...
that's beautiful so anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching, I also
want to mention that we are doing a
charity livestream tomorrow tomorrow and
Thursday. We will be doing, uh, new sales I
believe we have pajama pants and we have
special shirts available and also will
be doing giveaways it's spread over two
days, six hours a piece, so hopefully
everyone will be able to stop by and
join tomorrow, 12:00 pee-a-yum p.m. Pacific
Standard Time to 6:00, and then Thursday
at probably the same time so thank you
everybody so much for watching!!!! If you
want your comment read put it down in
the comments below or anywhere else on
the channel or even anywhere outside on
the social medias. I will be checking
tumblr, Twitter, Facebook, I want to look
all over the place for these comments so
thank you everybody so much for watching...
and as always I will see you in the next
video! BUH BYEEE!!!!